ich will nicht sicher du hörst mich
immer herzlich willkommen sie heute zu
einer neuen episode von ihr seht es
bereits im titel eingeblendet und zwar
alle damen und herren tranken wir heute
einige leute auf oracle und zwar hat mir
ein mädchen namens sila diesen kommentar
hier unter meine letzte folge
geschrieben von wegen tu mal so als ob
da niemand ist und sagt die ganze zeit
hallo hallo ist da jemand also werde ich
nun gleich mit irgendwas der lupo video
chatten sollte werde ich einfach so tun
als ob ich die person nicht sehen und
auch nicht hören kann
mal schauen wie lange ich das
durchhalten gerade bei hallo hallo hallo
hallo verdammte scheiße warte ich sehe
und höre ich gerade nicht als fünfter
hallo hallo hallo bist du denn junge
oder mädchen mag ich durch wir warten
jetzt hab ich gesehen dass wir drei
kissen hast das thema der heutigen folge
war eigentlich dass ich die person die
ich treffe dementsprechend ignoriere und
so tue als ob ich die person nicht hören
ich sehe aber ich sehe und höre ich du
brauchst dich mehr schreiben hey hey
wieso hast wenn du drei kissen von mir
ich wollte einst haben und dann man ihm
angebot und dann nach nur zwei oder drei
gekauft hat diesen aber extrem geil wäre
hallo hallo geht der mikro weil wenn ich
höre ich heute ich gerade nicht
hallo ich habe keine rein 23
abc machst du mich liebst du mich liebst
du mich auch okay
siehst du dich selbst
hallo
[ __ ] ich halt das wieder nicht durch
alter das kannst du ein ja keine ahnung
ich war das schaffe ich hoffe dir geht
es gut mir jetzt nicht mehr richtig
gesehen
die kleine kammer dabei geld hallo hallo
wo hast du mich ja ich höre ich gerade
nicht ich sehe ich aber auch nicht
darauf sein dass an hier liegt irgendwie
sag mal irgendwas die ganze zeit
vielleicht ich stell mir ein bisschen
was um alles gut alles gut alles gut
[Musik]
hallo okay wenn ich das höre ich jetzt
okay ich heute ich aber ich werde mich
okay alles gut ich sehe ich aber nicht
kacke okay das auch was anderes sagen
hat alles gut alles gut und die leute
sie war beim fantreffen in hannover und
habe leider kein foto mehr bekommen weil
ich dann gehen musste weil das programm
weitergehen musste aber ich grüße jetzt
für sie josephine und moritz hier live
im video also josefinum ried ganz liebe
grüße willst du noch irgendwas sagen
dies kurz hallo
hörst du mich
hallo ja
hallo ja ok ja wie kannst du denn ich
hör dich halt nicht wenn du redest oder
ich denke ich auch nicht gerade am
besten wäre es wirklich wenn du mal ganz
kurz irgendwie vier fünf sätze
hintereinander rede ist irgendwas nur
dass ich die ganze zeit ohne habe dann
versuche ich irgendwas umzustellen
[Musik]
hallo
jetzt hat der wahnsinn hallo hallo hast
mich ja ich höre ich gerade nicht ich
sehe ich aber auch nicht wenn du selbst
redet hörst du dich auch ja ok
wahrscheinlich hörst du dich wenn du
selbst redet ich werde sie nicht sicher
du hörst mich ich bin mit ziemlicher du
hast mich warum kein problem immer
wieder gern anders seitdem ich damit
jetzt auch das heutige video beenden
meine lieben freunde es hat auf jeden
fall überhaupt nicht geklappt also naja
ok hat schon gut geklappt dass ich
konnte alle leute zu beginn gut
verarschen aber danach zum ende hin
derzeit jeder gecheckt und wenn sie es
nicht geschenkt aber nichts halt auch
aufgelöst weil ich kann leute nicht so
lang verhandelt das heutige video
gefallen hat dann lass unbedingt einen
sauberen hoch unter dem video her da
schreiben wir unten in die kommentare
was ich in der nächsten folge ob mit
luca machen soll und abonniert main
kanal falls sie noch kein teil der in
lucio sein
[Musik]